ce sont les grands oubliés de la culture
elles sont venues manifester aujourd'hui
face au panthéon à paris
les guides conférencières en colère ils
dénoncent des conditions de travail
précaires lors d'une manifestation
silencieuse à paris regarder des gisants
des pleureurs et une faucheuse une scène
censée représenter la mort du métier du
guide de guides conférenciers une
profession menacée depuis la crise
sanitaire pas de touristes pas de
revenus mais toujours un loyer à payer
les guides conférenciers demandent des
aides la part de l'état écouter ses
réactions
nous n'avons plus de travail donc pour
les guides salariés les japonais les
guides en japonais sont souvent salariés
donc nous n'avons plus de salaire et
même si nous sommes au chômage nous
avons nous pouvons avoir le chômage en
fait nous épuisons nos droits sans
pouvoir les recharger nous demandons
donc d'avoir une année blanche pour les
salariés puisque ne pouvons pas
recharger nos droits et des aides
jusqu'à ce que la reprise du travail se
fasse
peut-être en 2021 et surtout par exemple
pour les guides salariés en fait toutes
les réponses que nous avons sont faites
pour les auto entrepreneurs
le gouvernement est en train d'essayer
de pousser les guînes vers l'auto
entreprenariat on essaye de se rendre
visible et surtout de lutter contre eux
une mort certaine annoncé étant donné
qu' une partie des guides plutôt
importante n'est toujours pas aidé donc
on avait promis au moment du début de
cette crise que personne ne serait
laissé au bord de la route
malheureusement il ya des personnes qui
passent dans les trous de la raquette et
les guides conférenciers salariés en
font partie mais là l'urgence absolue ce
sont les guides conférenciers salariés
pour la plupart multi employeurs en
mission très courte l'ambition d'une
demi journée à huit jours si vous partez
en circuit mais il ya du travail
y'a pas de touriste on le voit bien dans
pareilles a pas de touristes